well listen man uh you got a lot going
on uh when's episode two come out with
Christian rock and blue free Tuesday at
night 10 p.m Eastern on revolt and then
the YouTube is Wednesday Wednesday yep
Monday is the audio Monday is the audio
you can download the J sleep Thursday is
after dark Wednesday night after dark
Friday is the Jason Lee Yes Thursdays
we're giving them a break Thursday
nothing going on yeah I mean you can
really you can take a break you could
take a break yeah uh Hollywood unlocked
uh anything else you want to plug uh
you're you've obviously got your charity
nah just you know I'm just living life I
appreciate you know people like you
doing your homework and being a good
internet I'm a fan man I think you're
dope and like I I you know you got into
it with a friend of mine uh Peter
rosenberg's my boy you know but but no
no but it's funny because when you got
in into it with him I had your side did
you really yeah because I did you talk
to him about it no but I I like dm'd him
about or something I I just I I thought
that like I actually forgot what
actually the argument was about but I
think in terms you were kind of speaking
from somebody who's like an owner who
owns your [__] well and I appreciate it
I'll say this okay Peter if you're
watching I love Pete man that's my guy I
never wanted to hate on Peter and he's a
good he's a great guy he probably is
with like pure intention here's my deal
don't [__] start [__] with me like I
literally be minding my business unless
it's my business to mind the business
that we're speaking right I never hated
him I never you know he's whatever he's
Peter Roseburg he's built his name and
I'm building mine but I do take it
personal when people personally when
they personalize and attack me and think
that I'm not gonna attack back so I did
say to Noriega yo I'm coming on drink
chance bro I'm gonna [__] come on
there and just talk my [__] but I even
telling Peter Rosenberg and I wasn't
even focused on Peter but once he asked
for about Peter on the show I made it by
him but I did see recently like he kinda
I think he emailed me or DM me or
something I think he tried to connect
with me and we haven't connected he's a
nice guy yeah but I did say [__] HOT97
as a company [__] that whole brand [__]
everybody over there is up we don't
support them they recently tried to
interview me at someone [__] them no and
you know what until they make good and
make you because I'm not sucking
nobody's dick no pun intended for a
[__] look because I have the look I
have the platform already I'm not gonna
do that I don't need to go do a [__]
radio run with you know these [__]
losers Ebro from from Sacramento before
he was he was from Sac but I knew era
before but you know he has selective
memory I don't know if his agent or what
he just forgot me he doesn't remember
but whatever but I had a lot of respect
for Ebro as like the local Molly Mall
from Stockton absolutely I grew up with
Molly maybe my brother were best friends
yeah but you know I don't hate Ebro
either I'm just not I don't I don't you
know I'm I'm not none of these I'm not
subservient to none of these guys Ebro
still comments on Hollywood I'm like we
haven't blocked him you know we haven't
I don't even blocked a lot of people
though huh what's The Blacklist over
there but more than a thousand nah nah
we really don't block people like
because what about you me oh my [__]
yeah my [__] yeah yeah I got at least I
got at least 2 000 people blocked I
don't have that many or the early Love
and Hip-Hop days yeah like when people
like leave some like when I would like
say some political [__] and some Mega
[__] be in my comments of block
but you can filter your comments now and
you can restrict people so they don't
know you blocked them I restrict people
I don't block them when you restrict
them they can't leave comments no more
yeah but but I will say Floyd told me a
long time ago why would you give
somebody the privilege of knowing they
got your attention because if you
because if you block them they're like
oh they I got to him right he's like I
don't know he was like I don't I don't
even you know but of course he's a
billionaire so